un procès de quatre mois des événements
qui remontent à plus de dix ans un
jugement 233 pages et un verdict clair
coupable le juge de la cour du québec
normand bonnet a lu une partie son
jugement aux deux accusés
robert poirier ex maire de boisbriand et
france michaud ancienne vice présidente
de la firme roche
une lecture qui a duré plus d'une heure
et demie il déclare que les deux accusés
sont coupables de fraude de complot pour
fraude et d'abus de confiance
la couronne est pleinement satisfaite du
jugement
d'autant plus que c'est le premier
dossier de l'unité permanente
anticorruption qui sera à procès pour ce
type de crime
alors le jugement qui a été rendu
aujourd'hui reconnaît en fait que ce
type de stratagème et de faits criminels
en vertu du code criminel
le tribunal n'a pas cru le témoignage de
robert poirier
la couronne a fait la preuve hors de
tout doute qu'il y avait entente entre
la ville et les firmes d'ingénierie pour
l'attribution de contrats
elle a aussi prouvé que monsieur poirier
recevait énormément de cadeaux des
billets pour des spectacles et des
événements sportifs
le juge dit que tous ces cadeaux avaient
une valeur des mesures et des milliers
de dollars robert poirier se dit surpris
et songe à contester le jugement
j'ai dit que j'ai respecté les lois ni
loi de l'époque aujourd'hui ses autres
autres autres temps autres moeurs
mais j'ai respecté les lois pour celle
qui a dénoncé publiquement ce stratagème
en 2005 et qui est maintenant la
mairesse de boisbriand
ce jugement vient donner de bons
arguments à la ville pour intenter des
procédures en vue de récupérer l'argent
des contribuables est maintenant le rôle
de mon administration c'est de récupérer
les sommes qui ont été injustement
suggéré aux citoyens de boisbriand et
qui se chiffrent probablement en
centaines de milliers de dollars
les représentations sur sentence ont
prévu pour janvier 2016
la peine maximale prévue pour fraude et
de 14 ans d'emprisonnement
ici karen bastien radio canada
saint-girons